The night was their kingdom, those Gothic poets of the 19th century men who believed the sun was a tyrant, a cruel overseer of the waking world.
They slept until noon, if they slept at all, and spent their evenings drowning in opium or ink, greeting the dawn like a defeated soldier.
They called it freedom.
We call it the first great experiment in what we now know as social jet lag.
Your body has a clock. Not the kind that ticks on a wall, but something far older, far more insistent to circadian rhythm that hums beneath your skin, dictating when you should eat, when you should sleep, when you should even think.
Most people try to align with it. They wake with the sun, sleep when the world grows still.
But alignment is for the content. For the truly miserable, there is only desynchronization.
Imagine your body as a ship, perpetually crossing time zones without ever docking.
The engines never stop. The crew never rests.
This is the metabolic trap of social jet lag, not just a misalignment, but a full-blown rebellion against biology itself.
Studies show it doesn't just steal sleep. It steals clarity, focus, even the will to move.
Your body becomes a factory running on fumes, producing depression, weight gain, the slow erosion of cognitive sharpness.
And the worst part? You don't even notice. You just feel tired.
Always tired.
Now, let's make it worse.
First, there's the blue light bath.
Spend two hours before bed staring into the abyss of your screens, laughing at memes, scrolling through feeds, pretending you're doing something productive.
The light doesn't just keep you awake. It lies to your brain.
Melatonin, that little hormone that whispers night to your cells, gets drowned out.
Your body stays in day mode, even as the world outside darkens.
You're not just awake. You're tricked.
Then comes the snooze purgatory.
Set your alarm an hour too early just enough to drag you back from the edge of sleep, but not enough to let you rest.
Nine minutes.
That's all it takes. Nine minutes of grogginess.
Nine minutes of your brain still half-drowned in dreams, and you do it again, and again.
Each press of that button is a cannonball dropped into the hull of your day.
By the time you finally stumble out of bed, the ship is already listing.
You're not just tired.
You're sunk.
Never wake up at the same time twice.
Three hours.
That's the golden mean of chaos.
One day you're a night owl.
The next, a morning lark.
The next, somewhere in between.
Your body never knows what to expect.
It can't predict.
It can't prepare.
And so it runs on fumes, a perpetual motion machine of exhaustion.
And the food, oh.
The food.
Save your biggest meal for after eleven.
Let your stomach work while the rest of you tries to shut down.
Your digestive system is a rebel, too, churning away while your brain begs for silence.
Sleep becomes a storm, your refuge a battlefield.
This is the life of the eternal traveler.
You are never quite here, never quite there.
Time isn't a river anymore.
It's a series of puddles, irritating, disconnected, impossible to cross.
You're tired when you're awake, wired when you should be sleeping, a paradox wrapped in flesh.
Waking up is a mistake.
Every snooze is another cannonball.
By the time you finally leave the bed, the day is already lost.
The sun is the boss of the world, after all.
And the only freedom left is the void.
Pre-compantly trying to dolls are stuck today.
Thank you.
You're tired.
You're just a semblance.
We're a request.
Thank you.
We're here today.
Take care and listen.
Create a picture.
I'll really work.
And put your tactics on yourself today.
Take care.
Bye.
This is the first time we've got Eight.
Mens.
I'll be in person with my little elementary.
I'll be together.
I'll be working tomorrow.
I'll be here tomorrow.
Please continue.
Be careful.